a busy day at one of Delhi's biggest
private hospitals businessman ben waka
bene has traveled all the way from Congo
with his family to get a kidney
transplant a procedure that isn't easily
available in many African countries the
surgery was carried out here two weeks
ago his son Ilan's donated the kidney
doctors have advised Benoit to wear a
mask to protect himself from Delhi's
notorious dust I didn't expect such good
treatment in India the doctors and
Surgeons are excellent and I already
feel better it's given me hope that I
can go back home and begin to work and
live like a normal person
the new Aqaba need five dollars for his
treatment overseas patients increasingly
from africa are a common sight in many
indian hospitals fueling the country's
thriving medical tourism market
hospitals like Mac's in Delhi have
sought to cash in on the boom
International patients make up close to
20% of the institution's annual revenue
dedicated centers for foreign patients
are now an essential part of the service
they offer help with everything from
finding translators processing forms to
finding accommodation well it's the
access to quality health care at a
fraction of the costs of of both South
Africa and Europe which for the two
traditional markets for Africans to
travel for treatment so as they've
started to come to India the the word of
mouth is spreading that the quality of
health care is e : and the costs are a
fraction so that's the way it's building
up over time for Africans like Benoit
Kamini who can't afford it India's
appeal as a medical destination is only
set to grow